It turns out that when you
are wolfing down all that ice
cream, and your dog looks
at you like it's ashamed,
it's because it's ashamed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Anthony here, for DNews.
And in the past, we've
thought that dogs
are pretty simplistic,
emotionally.
While owners thought their
dogs saw them as best friends,
science said it's more
like trustworthy guardian.
Where owners saw
sympathy, science
said, emotional transference
and anthropomorphism.
But a bunch of new
findings recently
show that dogs and a
lot of other animals
might have the same
emotional depth that we do.
Gregory Berns is a
professor of neuroeconomics
at Emory University.
And over the last
few years, he's
been training dogs to sit
comfortably in an MRI.
Sit.
Previously, putting an animal
in an MRI required sedation
or just dealing with a crazy,
stressed-out animal, which
means we've never gotten a
clear picture of how they think.
We've been going mostly
on behavioral study.
And let's be honest here, we
misread the behavior of humans
all the time.
And we can verbally
communicate with humans.
So--
Anyway, with calm, happy dogs
chilling in the brain tube,
they found some very
interesting activity going on,
particularly in an area
called the caudate nucleus.
It's a happy place--
well, an anticipation
of happiness place.
In humans, researchers can
look at the caudate nucleus,
and based on what part
of it is lighting up,
predict what we
like, what our tastes
are in things like
food or music.
It can even clue
them in into things
that we find
aesthetically beautiful.
In a dog, the caudate
lit up in response
to food or the
possibility of food.
It activated at the
sense of familiar humans.
It activated when their
owner walked into the room.
So the same part
of the brain that
lights up for love and
attachment and beauty
in a human lit up for
similar things in a dog.
Now that doesn't
necessarily mean
that a dog has got
a song that makes
them think of their
ex or anything,
but it's a functional homology.
Their brains work
like ours, so they
might have emotions like ours.
Other research lately
has been showing
a depth in emotion
and social memory
that we've never thought
animals were capable of.
We used to think that
friendship in animals
was based mostly on
reciprocity-- what
one animal can do for the
other to help it survive.
A recent study of
chimpanzees actually
showed it's based on something
called the similarity effect.
It's how we humans
choose friends.
We tend to like people who have
personalities or interests that
are like ours.
Chimps seem to do the same.
Sociable, outgoing chimps
flock to one another.
Emo chimps hung out under a
tree and smoked with other emo
chimps during lunch--
something like that.
Anyway--
Another study of
dolphins this year
showed that they can
remember the unique whistle
of their friends, even after
being apart for decades.
When a recording of
their buddy is played,
their mood improves, and
they go hunting around
in the tank to find
their lost friend.
More and more, it is looking
like animals feel things
as deeply as we do.
In his write-up of his
study in the New York Times,
Doctor Berns asks
how society would
have to change if
we can prove that.
What happens to lab animals,
pet stores, agriculture?
Would we have to define
what an animal is to us?
What do you think?
Do animals have
emotions like us?
Dagger, do you have emotions?
How did you feel at
the end of Twilight?
What is your five-year plan?
Feel free to answer any
of the questions I just
asked Dagger in the comments
and subscribe for more DNews.
And oh, Dagger, we're going
to be on Petopia, over
on Animalist, aren't we?
They can't talk. they can
feel, but they can't talk.
But he would say yes.
You should go check that out.